Horror movies might be filled with frights,
but they're usually pretty fun to watch, too.
Every now and again, however, there comes
along a scary movie that's so disturbing it's
hard to justify ever sitting through it again.
From extreme brutality to the true emotional torment
of audiences, these are the movies you'll
want to opt out of re-visiting after the first
run.
As always, beware the spoilers.
The Sacrament
Loosely based on true events, The Sacrament
is excruciatingly tense and takes the story
and its characters to some incredibly dark
places.
The faux-documentary features three reporters
investigating a new religious movement in
Africa.
And the climax depicts the ritual self-sacrifice
of the cult members, which does not flinch
from a single moment of the pain, confusion,
and fear they experience.
It gets particularly difficult to watch when
one of the reporters is tied down by his sister
and forced to participate in the ritual with
her.
In terms of craft, The Sacrament probably
is an incredibly well done movie.
"I tried.
God knows I tried."
But once you've watched the film and know
the places it will take you to, it's almost
impossible to watch again.
Martyrs
The "torture-horror" subgenre hit a new benchmark
with Martyrs.
The French film features characters experiencing
every kind of agony imaginable, from suffering
intense beatings to being flayed alive.
And it's the existential justification for
this cycle of sinister acts that's really
hard to bear.
The tormentors are attempting to gain knowledge
of the afterlife by turning their subjects
into martyrs who are abused into transcendance.
And after so much anguish and gruesome violence,
audiences are ultimately left to wonder what
the experience revealed, if anything.
It's an experience to watch this movie unfold,
but it is also an exhausting one for sure.
Funny Games
Sometimes bad things happen to good people
and there's no rhyme or reason to it.
Funny Games is a story about this very idea.
Two sociopathic youths, Peter and Paul, stage
a physical and emotional assault on a family
in their own home.
Bones are broken.
Lives are ended.
A dog goes to doggy heaven.
And all of this is done in service of a sick
game being played by the boys.
There is no backstory between the family and
the men torturing them.
It's not a revenge scheme, and there is no
plot twist revealing the boys to be the abandoned
children of the mother or the father.
Peter and Paul simply show up, commit countless
atrocities, and then move on to the next family.
Funny Games might be tremendously made, but
it is a horrifying film that presents sick
joy in senseless violence and probably won't
leave you reaching for the DVD again any time
soon.
The Invitation
Even without its twist ending, The Invitation
would be uncomfortable to sit through a second
time.
The film sets out to put the nuance of interactions
between lapsed friends under a microscope.
Through a few hours spent at a tense dinner
party, it analyzes the minute intricacies
of every awkward exchange between characters.
And it explores the efforts people will go
through to save face and stifle survival instincts
when cordial social interactions go to places
they shouldn't.
"Don't you guys think this is a little bit
weird?"
Furthermore, it's a stunning meditation on
grief and what people will do to cope with
loss.
These themes are explored very nicely, but
they're so heavy that a second viewing is
likely out of the question for most moviegoers.
And this is all before the film's third act,
which features the host couple trying to snuff
out all their friends and then off themselves
in the name of a mysterious spiritual group
they've joined.
All in all, it's an immaculate film that is
probably best left alone after a single viewing.
Lake Mungo
There are points at which Lake Mungo hardly
feels like a horror film.
The imitation-documentary plays out as a look
into how the loss of a loved one can devastate
the people around them over time.
There are supernatural elements to the film
and some great frights to be had, but they're
comparatively sparse across the movie's hour
and a half running time.
Those scares aren't what will keep viewers
from coming back for a second viewing, though.
That falls entirely on the subject matter.
By staging the film as a documentary with
no well-known actors to lower the audience's
suspension of disbelief, director Joel Anderson
amplifies the emotional devastation the Palmer
family experiences after the loss of their
daughter Alice.
And that plays directly into the supernatural
aspects of the plot, too.
Lake Mungo is a superb film, but one that
deals with some very heavy subject matter
and would be very hard to sit through a second
time.
Audition
Takashi Miike has released over 100 films,
and he could probably go on to direct 100
more with not one of them earning the reputation
that Audition has.
It's the story of a widower who, at the urging
of his son, connects with a young woman named
Asami.
As their romance develops, it becomes clear
that there is more to her than she lets on.
Suspicions build slowly towards the film's
serious climax, which features a horrific scene
of torture and a mutilated man Asami sadistically
keeps alive in a bag.
Other films featuring torture might try to
shock the audience with a wide array of methods,
but Miike instead pares it down to one excruciatingly
simple, prolonged moment of pain.
Audition is a masterpiece, no doubt about
it, and it's absolutely worth seeing.
But it's still a hard movie to get through
the first time around, and knowing what the
end holds will not make rewatching it any
easier.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!